[Musik]
STURMI: Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zurück >bei< Sallys Welt,
nicht >in< Sallys Welt.
Zusammen mit dem anderen von Murat.
[Grillengeräusche]
Hi, ich bin's, Fred - mega unangenehmer Anfang. Sollen wir nochmal?
SALLY: Herzlich willkommen!
Heute sind wir nicht in meiner Küche, sondern bei Sturmi zu Hause - endlich.
STURMI: Büro.
SALLY: Wir haben es geschafft. Ja, im Büro, mein Gott.
Aber komm, es ist doch dein 2. Zuhause.
STURMI: Ich lebe hier. Also ich gehe nur noch zum Schlafen nach Hause.
SALLY: Ich wollte eigentlich auch meine Wäsche hier waschen,
aber er hat keine Waschmaschine.
STURMI: Ich habe dir gesagt, du kannst bei mir zu Hause waschen.
SALLY: Jedenfalls sind wir gerade in Köln und …
Josh, ich wasche deine Wäsche auch mit, okay? [Josh bejaht]
Jedenfalls sind wir gerade in Köln
und drehen gerade eine „Pimp my Kitchen"-Folge.
Viele haben schon vermutet, dass ich deine Küche pimpe.
Aber hallo, hier gibt's doch gar nichts zu pimpen.
STURMI: Nein, wir haben mal darüber gesprochen vor einem Jahr.
SALLY: Die ist der Hammer.
STURMI: [Doing] Nicht rausschneiden!
SALLY: Über die Schubladen können wir noch einmal reden,
aber ich finde, so ist die echt ordentlich. [Sturmi stimmt zu]
Schubladeninnensysteme kommen dann irgendwann.
STURMI: Ja, du hast ja Josh.
Das ist ja dein unfairer Vorteil.
Der bastelt dir das ja alles immer für die Schubladen.
Das habe ich nicht.
SALLY: Ich sage immer: Josh, Guck mal, da und da
und dann ist es immer so - zack!
Ja, aber du hast doch mich. Ich mache das.
STURMI: Du machst das? [Sally bejaht]
Das, was aus der Josh normalerweise für dich macht,
machst du für mich? [Sally bejaht]
Schubladeninnensysteme für meine Backschublade würdest du bauen?
[Aufschrei]
SALLY: Oh Gott, mach sie wieder zu!
STURMI: Sieht gut aus.
Wir haben es nicht rausgeschnitten.
SALLY: [Lacht] Sieht super aus.
Ja, ich möchte heute mich der Challenge stellen.
Du hast mich ja gechallenged.
STURMI: Ich soll …
eigentlich 3 Spätzlerezepte machen,
aber ich wusste nicht, dass ich hier mit einbezogen werde.
Deswegen machen wir 1 Konter-Rezept, was du gemacht hast.
SALLY: Okay.
STURMI: Weil du hast mich gechallenged zu Spätzle machen
und dann habe ich dich zurück gechallenged.
SALLY: Ja, und jetzt machen wir Spätzle auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise,
und zwar süß.
Es wird ein Spätzle-Dessert.
STURMI: Wird's lecker? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Hast schon mal was von mir gegessen, was nicht lecker war?
Du darfst ehrlich sein.
STURMI: Nein, tatsächlich nicht.
Was ich aber schon mal bei dir gemacht habe, ist,
ich hab mir was den kleinen Finger abgeschnitten.
SALLY: Ja. Boah, hör auf! Ich erinnere mich.
Okay, wir machen jetz … Boah!
STURMI: Kann mir jemand kurz Essig in die Frau schütten? [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Okay, also erst einmal der Spätzle-Grundteig.
Das Rezept gibt es schon auf meinem Kanal:
4 Eier, 400 g Mehl, bisschen Salz,
Vanilleextrakt, weil süß, und Mineralwasser.
STURMI: Ein Schluck Sprudel.
Wenn du jetzt normale Spätzle machen würdest …
Ich frage das jetzt einfach mal.
Den Kontext musst du nicht wissen.
Aber wenn du normale Käsespätzle machen würdest,
würdest du in den Teig Milch mit reinnehmen oder ist das eine Todsünde?
SALLY: Ich habe es noch nicht gemacht,
aber ich verwende einfach immer nur Wasser.
STURMI: Milch wäre schon …
Das machen nur komische Leute, oder?
SALLY: Eigentlich gehört da keine Milch mit rein.
STURMI: Ja …
SALLY: Wer hat's gemacht?
[Bedrohliche Musik]
STURMI: Ich habe doch noch den Spätzle-Krieg mit Anja laufen.
und sie wollte gegen mich kontern.
Dann hat sie in ihren Spätzleteig Milch gemacht.
[Aufschrei]
SALLY: Hat sie nicht!
STURMI: Widerlich.
SALLY: Hat sie?
STURMI: Sie kriegt noch eine Antwort.
Anzeige. [Polizeisirene]
[Beide lachen]
Jetzt kommt Involvement hier gleich, das ist aber …
Ich habe hier nichts mit zu tun!
Direkt in die Spülmaschine.
Ja, so, die da rein?
SALLY: Genau, dann …
STURMI: Mehl, Zucker.
SALLY: Nein, Salz.
STURMI: Zucker.
SALLY: Ja komm, mach mal mit!
STURMI: Ach so, ja! Ich rühre… Damit? Nicht mit einem Schlägi?
SALLY: Schlägi?
STURMI: Ja, das ist ein Mixi-Schlägi.
SALLY: So viel direkt?
Das schaffst du! Und Vanilleextrakt für die Spätzle.
STURMI: Hast du das schon mal gemacht oder ist das jetzt …? [Sally verneint]
Ach wirklich?
Hat es heute Potenzial, dass es nicht gut wird?
SALLY: Vielleicht.
Ich habe vorhin Sarah die Zutaten diktiert und dann sagt sie so:
Sag mal, rätst du gerade?
Und ich so: Ja!
STURMI: Echt? [Sally bejaht]
Mutig von dir!
Wenn wir mal ein Kochbuch zusammen machen:
Schally, eh, Sally schätzt.
SALLY: [Lacht] Schally schätzt.
STURMI: Schally schätzt.
Dann machen wir das zusammen und geben es als Kinderkochbuch aus,
damit wir, wenn was nicht gelingt, sagen können:
Ach, das ist doch nur, dass sie mal in die Küche kommen.
SALLY: Und ich will betonen,
dass wir auch gerade keine Waage hatten,
weil ich sie vielleicht in die Spüle gelegt habe,
weil ich dachte, es wäre keine Waage.
STURMI: Du hast meine Waage umgebracht?
SALLY: Es tut mir leid.
Jetzt geht sie nicht mehr.
D.h., das Mehl ist auch geschätzt.
Richtig! Was geht denn mir das Sally heute?
STURMI: Das ist echt so.
Weil du heute Morgen, glaube ich, den Tafelessig einfach … [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Schön! Jetzt schön immer Mehl und Wasser.
[Musik]
Geht, oder?
STURMI: Sollte funktionieren.
SALLY: Ja, den jetzt schon schlagen und dann lassen wir den kurz ruhen
und können ja in der Zwischenzeit …
STURMI: Noch den einen oder anderen Podcast aufnehmen,
SALLY: einen Podcast aufnehmen, die Früchte und die Creme zubereiten.
Machen wir alles parallel.
Schön, eine richtige Maschine!
STURMI: Ich tu nur so. Mir tut alles weh. [Bemitleidendes >Ahhh<]
SALLY: Schön. Okay, dann bereite ich schon einmal die Zutaten.
für Creme und Früchte vor.
Ich kenne mich hier aus.
STURMI: Alles gut.
SALLY: Hat jemand bei euch eine Laktoseintoleranz?
Ja, fast alle. [Doing]
STURMI: Passt alles? [Sally stimmt zu]
Was brauchst du alles für die Creme?
SALLY: Quark, Puderzucker, Sahne, Vanille.
STURMI: Vanille?
SALLY: Vanille!
STURMI: Willst du eine größere?
SALLY: Ja, ich nehme eine größere zum Rühren.
Das ist nur meine Schlüssel zum Zeigen.
STURMI: Also, ich muss sagen, ich hätte dir ganz viel Anerkennung gegeben,
wenn du darin jetzt die ganze Creme …
Sehr langsam und sehr vorsichtig.
SALLY: Das machen wir nicht.
Hast du ein Handrührgerät?
Ja, stimmt. Ja, das hast du natürlich.
Also da haben wir jetzt für die Creme
500 g Quark, 400 g Sahne, 80 g Puderzucker (geschätzt), 1 Bio-Limette.
Das finde ich übrigens voll cool. Das ist da eingeprägt.
Was habt ihr für coole Limetten? Guck mal.
STURMI: Ähm ja, das gibt es bei uns im Supermarkt.
SALLY: Richtig cool.
STURMI: Aber auch Limetten könnt ihr bei Lidl holen. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Und Vanilleextrakt.
Und was hast du da?
STURMI: Ich habe gefrorene Himbeeren.
Ja, die sind kühl.
SALLY: Ja, die sind noch gefroren.
Dann bisschen Zucker.
STURMI: Habe ich auch.
SALLY: So ungefähr 40-50 g, und?
STURMI: Tonka Wonka.
Sehr lecker. Also auch sehr gut.
Und auch wenn das fast leer ist,
könnt ihr das aufmachen, mit Hafermilch durchschütteln
und in euren Kaffee geben.
Gibt bestimmt auch mit Vanilleextrakt, oder?
SALLY: Genau.
STURMI: Haben wir natürlich schon gemacht.
SALLY: Okay, jetzt verrühren wir kurz die Creme, also Quark rein.
Also Limettenabrieb kommt da rein.
Machst du denn Saft?
STURMI: Yes! Ich hab hier schon alles vorbereitet,
ist natürlich frisch geschärft.
klar, weil ich es schon eine Weile nutze.
SALLY: Puderzucker.
Und jetzt hoffe ich einfach, dass die Schüsselgröße reicht.
STURMI: Komplett? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Ja, die reicht doch.
Habe ich jetzt schon Vanille rein? Nein, habe ich noch nicht.
Machen wir noch Vanille rein.
Und dann die Sahne zugießen.
STURMI: Ich habe eine Frage zum Backtrennspray.
Das ist noch mein allererstes, was ich von dir bekommen habe.
Ich backe jetzt nicht so oft.
Das ist ja jetzt noch etwas drin,
aber wenn ich das jetzt anmache …
Sprüh mal im besten Fall hier rein.
SALLY: Du musst die Düse auswaschen.
STURMI: Ach so, okay, das ist es.
SALLY: Das ist, wenn man es stehen lässt.
STURMI: Und es riecht nach Sonnencreme. Ist das normal?
SALLY: Du musst sie einfach mal …
STURMI: Nicht Backtrennspray, sondern Sonnenspray.
Aber es liegt tatsächlich nur an der Düse? [Sally bejaht]
Ja okay, das ist natürlich auch …
Hier bitte nicht ins Detail gehen.
Können wir kurz … Time-out?
[Beep]
SALLY: Dann geben wir jetzt noch den Limettensaft dazu
und dann einfach so ein bisschen cremig rühren, so halb steif schlagen.
Die muss ja nicht ganz fest sein.
Ja, das reicht dann schon.
Ich versuche, höher zu stellen.
Krass, die Schüsselgröße reicht.
STURMI: Und die Lautstärke auch.
SALLY: Ja, der Sturmi hat nämlich gerade erzählt …
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das richtig drauf hatten.
STURMI: Ja.
SALLY: dass deine Maschine lauter ist als unsere.
STURMI: Richtig, weil …
SALLY: Wir haben jetzt rausgefunden, warum.
STURMI: Ich wusste nicht
bzw. meine lieben Kommentator:innen haben mir geschrieben,
weil ich die immer so nach hinten gelehnt habe stehen lassen.
Der Hintergrund: dass das Getriebeöl, das hier drin ist,
nach hinten fließt und dementsprechend die Maschine schwergängiger wird.
Deswegen ist meine auch deutlich lauter als eure.
Heißt, wenn man eine KitchenAid hat,
immer nach Betrieb wieder so lagern,
weil sonst …
Ich muss sie dringend mal aufmachen und noch mal nachölen,
weil sie sonst kaputtgeht.
Das war nämlich der Josef.
SALLY: Der Josef muss …
Wollen wir einmal probieren, weil wir ja auch keine Waage hatten,
weil ich sie gespült habe.
Limette könnte noch ein bisschen mehr, ein bisschen mehr.
STURMI: Findest du?
SALLY: Wir lassen sie so, weil noch die Himbeeren dazu kommen.
STURMI: Ich wollte gerade sagen. Ich finde sie auch ganz gut eigentlich.
Wird sonst zu sauer, oder?
SALLY: So, dann ist die Creme fertig
und ich stelle sie kurz in den Kühlschrank.
Ist da Platz?
STURMI: Ja, ich glaube schon.
SALLY: Das ist aus Edelstahl.
Deswegen können wir es in die Spülmaschine packen.
STURMI: Auch im Shop in Mannheim gibt es KitchenAids zu kaufen.
Mussten wir das schon?
SALLY: Okay, hier geben wir ein bisschen Zucker und Tonka Wonka rein.
Oh, das ist ja schon offen. Hast du benutzt?
STURMI: Ja klar.
SALLY: Magst du rühren?
STURMI: Einfach nur so? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Und dann nehmen wir noch Salz.
STURMI: Ich überlege gerade.
Womit mache ich das am besten? Ich habe nur noch sowas.
Wie gefällt dir Köln?
SALLY: Gut! Dir?
STURMI: Wollt ihr hinziehen?
SALLY: Ja. Oder Du kommst zu uns, haben wir doch gesagt.
STURMI: Wie ist bei euch die Gewerbesteuer?
SALLY: Die ist hoch.
STURMI: Waghäusel ist hoch?
SALLY: Sehr gut.
Hast du so kleine süße …
STURMI: Jetzt sage ich schon nein.
SALLY: Dessert-Gläschen?
STURMI: Ich gehe mal aus der Küche. So.
Und dann erst die Himbeeren, dann die
Creme, dann die Spätzle? [Sally bejaht] Schichten tatsächlich?
SALLY: Ja, wir machen so ein Schicht-Dessert.
STURMI: Spätzle-Schicht … Boah, das ist fast ein Zungenbrecher.
SALLY: Spätzle-Schicht-Dessert.
STURMI: Spätzle-Schicht-Dessert.
SALLY: Wir machen, oh, ich weiß es.
Wir machen jetzt die Spätzle
und dann karamellisieren wir sie noch in Karamellbutter.
Dann kommen jetzt unten die Himbeeren.
Ich habe tatsächlich das Rezept
einfach heute Morgen dann so bisschen weiter improvisiert.
Ich habe dir ja gestern Zutaten geschickt, was ich brauche
und dann wusste ich noch nicht so genau, was ich mache.
Dann habe ich improvisiert.
Wir machen jetzt unten eine schöne Fruchtschicht mit den Himbeeren rein,
dann die Vanille-Limetten-Creme obendrauf
und darüber karamellisierte Tonka-Spätzle.
STURMI: Kennst du Chefkoch.de? [Alle lachen]
SALLY: Nein, sagt mir gar nichts.
STURMI: Ich meine natürlich Sallys Blog,
wo ihr auch dieses Rezept hier, falls es gleich lecker aussieht,
nachmachen könnt.
Bewirb uns mal.
Okay, okay, danke.
SALLY: Wir kennzeichnen es oben.
Ach so, einfach über mein Gesicht.
Spätzle-Schaber haben wir nicht mehr.
STURMI: Haben wir, also doch, haben wir.
SALLY: Aber wir wissen nicht, wo. Soll ich nochmal suchen?
STURMI: Hmm.
Wenn, dann, glaube ich, da unten rechts oder so.
Vielleicht ist er in die Backutensilien
in dem offenen Regal gewandert oder so.
SALLY: Hast du nicht meine Edelstahl-Teigkarte?
STURMI: [Wah wah wah Soundeffekt] Nein, habe ich nicht.
Da haben wir schon mal bei dir drüber geredet.
SALLY: Wow. Der killt das Messer.
Jutta ist die Beste! Jutta, komm bitte einmal in Sturmis Küche.
STURMI: Jutta hat das Auge.
Jutta in den Kommentaren loben.
SALLY: [Applaus und Jubel]
Jutta findet sogar hier alles. Sehr cool!
Komm, das machen wir so.
Und wenn du willst, kannst du ja eigentlich schon einmal das da …
STURMI: Die da reinmachen? [Sally bejaht]
Von meinem Löffelchen ein Drittel oder …?
SALLY: Warte, wir gucken einmal.
Komm, wir nehmen so ein Löffelchen.
Schön den Rand sauber lassen.
[Verzerrte Stimme zitiert Sally] Schön den Rand sauber lassen.
[Beep]
STURMI: Ja, hat funktioniert.
Ich sag mal so: Am Ende weiß jeder, wer was gemacht hat.
SALLY: So sieht es gut aus.
Bist du Spätzle-Master?
STURMI: Ich kann das gerne machen. Ja, klar.
SALLY: So, ich nehme noch eine Tasse. Äh … [Lacht]
eine Pfanne zum Karamellisieren,
hole noch die Butter aus dem Kühlschrank.
Ich kenne mich hier schon richtig aus.
STURMI: Vielleicht brauchst du doch wieder eine kleinere Küche.
Ich kann mal …
SALLY: Josh, das ist mal … Butter!
Fett! Das ist mal eine große Portion.
STURMI: Es gab kein flüssiges mehr.
Hier ist es muckelig, ne? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Das ist zum Rausholen.
STURMI: Richtig. Und dann machen wir mal …
SALLY: Wo waren deine Backzutaten? Hier, oder?
STURMI: Du, ich mache aber schon immer so, ich sag mal,
ein bisschen gröbere Spätzle - die sind schon Oschis,
sagt man, glaube ich.
Oschis? Ja!
Kommt es vom Schwäbischen?
Habt ihr Oschis gekapert?
SALLY: Guck an, guck an! Wie ein Profi!
[Hip Hop-Sound]
[Beep]
STURMI: Der Schwabe - das Einzige, was er kann.
SALLY: Nein!
Ich hacke jetzt noch Cashewkerne und die werden mit karamellisiert.
Ey, das wird ein Hammerdessert, hoffe ich!
STURMI: 11 Uhr Morgen. [Lacht]
SALLY: 11 Uhr ist bei uns schon so … Da haben wir …
STURMI: Dessert.
SALLY: Bei uns hat der Josh um 11 Uhr schon 2 Torten probieren müssen.
So, Cashewkerne hier rein, aber mir fällt ein.
Wir hätten eine größere Pfanne nehmen können,
weil darin die Spätzle geschwenkt werden.
STURMI: Dann machen wir 1-2 für das Bild.
Den Rest machen wir später in der größeren.
SALLY: [Doing] So machst du das?
STURMI: Ach so, ich meine natürlich.
Wir können das alles auch in der Pfanne problemlos nachmachen.
SALLY: Okay, sieht doch schon mal gut aus.
STURMI: Es wird besser.
SALLY: Also hier schön die Cashewkerne mit Zucker karamellisieren.
Es wird, sieht super aus!
Man sieht den schwäbischen Ursprung.
Ich bin dafür, dass wir zwei jetzt das Bündnis schließen
- 2021 zwischen Baden und Schwaben.
STURMI: Baschwaben? [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Man nennt es auch Baden-Württemberg.
[Heroische Musik]
STURMI: Könnt ihr uns Power Rangers-Kostüme animieren,
während wir das gemacht haben?
SALLY: Der Tag heute geht in die Geschichte ein. Ich sag's euch!
Wenn das das Ganze schön hellbraun ist, …
STURMI: Das war so schrecklich unspektakulär. [Lacht]
SALLY: Das war genauso unspektakulär wie unser App-Launch damals.
Alle so drauf gewartet und da war noch nicht mal ein Countdown.
Das war so: Tada, die App ist da.
STURMI: 13:47 Uhr, cool, let's go.
SALLY: Okay, und hier kommt jetzt Butter rein.
Ist bei dir nach dem Dreh auch immer gleich aufgeräumt?
STURMI: Ja, ja, mache ich alles direkt. Den ganzen Tag stehe ich hier.
Mein Hobby ist ja Aufräumen, musst du wissen.
Deswegen verstehen wir uns auch gut.
SALLY: Du machst das wirklich gerne, oder? [Sally bejaht]
STURMI: Ich habe Sally mal tatsächlich privat gefragt, als ich vor Ort war,
und meinte: Hey, hier sieht es ja schon immer sehr gut aus.
Wie machst du das? Dann hat sie zu mir gesagt:
Mein Hobby ist Aufräumen
Und Putzen.
SALLY: Ich habe meinen Kärcher dabei.
Darf später einmal …
STURMI: Wenn Murat bei euch draußen immer …
SALLY: Ich habe meinen Dampfreiniger dabei, meinen Fensterputzer
und den Saugwischer.
STURMI: Klar, kannst du natürlich!
SALLY: Für die Küche dort. Ich dachte, ich mache das einfach.
EKO: Entschuldigung, was passiert hier eigentlich?
STURMI: Was ist denn hier los?
[Jubel]
Das ist alles staatlich geeicht.
Wie ist das so schnell passiert?
EKO: Ich habe gehört …
STURMI: Du hast noch einen Schlüssel, oder?
[Dante und Sally begrüßen sich.]
EKO: (Das ist ein Spätzle-Battle - wer bessere Spätzle zubereitet, okay?)
(Weißt du, was das ist?)
DANTE: (Ich kann es mir in etwa vorstellen.)
(Aber selbst wenn ich es nicht weiß - Hauptsache, es schmeckt gut!)
EKO: (Das finden wir heraus. Wir müssen aber bestimmen, wer bessere Spätzle macht.)
(Sturmi hat aber nicht einmal die Erlaubnis, Spätzle zuzubereiten,
denn er ist aus Mönchengladbach.)
SALLY: (Aber er ist ein originaler Schwabe.)
EKO: (Ah okay. Entschuldigung!)
SALLY: Ich habe dich in Schutz genommen.
STURMI: Danke schön!
MURAT: Sowas passiert nur in Köln, dass irgendwelche Leute reinplatzen.
Bei uns in Waghäusel kommt nur der Postbote und hier die ganzen …
STURMI: Und immer mal wieder Kai Pflaume,
aber den musst wieder rausschmeißen.
EKO: Hier kommen die ganzen Rapper rein.
Hey, sorry, ich wollte nicht so reinplatzen.
Ich habe internationale Unterstützung dabei.
Wie geht es euch denn heute? Wie lange seid ihr denn schon da?
STURMI: Du, wir sind schon ein bisschen dran,
damit mit wir gleich ein gutes Dessert haben.
Es wird amazing!
SALLY: Es war etwas ungewöhnlich für ihn,
heute morgen um halb neun zu starten,
aber hey, es läuft gut.
DANTE: (Ich habe mich immer gefragt, wie Spätzle zubereitet wird.
Jetzt verstehe ich, wie sie das machen.
Wie geht das, fragte ich mich immer.
So geht das also.)
STURMI: (Es dauert ein bisschen, aber jede einzelne ist deutsche Handwerkskunst, sodass sie noch besser schmecken)
EKO: (Ich liebe diese Menschen und schaue ihnen zu.
Ich versuche immer, wie sie zu kochen, aber leider vergebens.
Ich gebe mein Bestes!)
Danke schön.
STURMI: Jetzt wird's hier richtig wild!
DANTE: (Meine Frau ist hier. Sie wird auch zuschauen.)
SALLY: So, jetzt gibt es ein Spätzle-Battle,
So ein richtiges Spätzle-Battle - How to make Spätzle.
STURMI: Ja, sehr gut.
Die beiden können jetzt auch mal schaben.
SALLY: Natürlich, die sind schon ausgestattet.
STURMI: Los geht's.
Und dann einfach nur noch stückchenweise. Genau, that's it.
Das ist es schon.
Guckst du mal?
SALLY: Oh Gott, mein Karamell.
Oh Gott, wow!
STURMI: Aber passt noch.
DANTE: (Fast zu lange.)
SALLY: (Es ist okay.)
DANTE: (Du hast sie rechtzeitig gerettet.)
EKO: Das ist blöd, so viele reinzutun,
aber man muss sie wahrscheinlich ziemlich dünn machen, richtig?
STURMI: Ja, kannst du dünn oder etwas dicker machen.
Bei denen ist ja auch alles so wild durcheinander, weißt du?
Das ist ja, glaube ich auch, eben Spätzle.
DANTE: (Was sind die Zutaten? Wir habt ihr Spätzle zubereitet?)
STURMI: (Einfach nur Mehl, Sprudel, also Wasser mit Kohlensäure.)
DANTE: (Mit Kohlensäure? Muss das sein?) [Sturmi bejaht]
(In Amerika nutzt man solches Wasser nicht. Da nutzt man stilles Wasser.)
STURMI: (Hier passiert das nicht. Hier wollen sie für alles Geld.)
(Und dann noch Salz und Eier. Das war's so ziemlich.)
EKO: (Gib dein Bestes!)
DANTE: (Alles klar! Dann wollen wir mal.)
STURMI: (Ein bisschen drauf legen.)
DANTE: (Okay. Vielen Dank!)
STURMI: (Es ist etwas klebrig.)
EKO: (Dann lasst uns mal sehen, ob Amerikaner Spätzle zubereiten können!)
DANTE: (Das wird interessant!)
EKO: (Das ist Integration!)
STURMI: (Du musst es flach drücken und dann Wasser nutzen!)
DANTE: (Erst Wasser und dann schaben?)
STURMI: (Du kannst es einfach ein bisschen in Wasser tunken.)
(Ziehe es ein bisschen, dann wird es etwas einfacher.
Und dann kannst du es genau wie Eko machen.)
DANTE: (Ich werde das mal zu Hause nachmachen.
Sollte es total daneben gehen, habe ich es wenigstens versucht.)
STURMI: (Beschuldige einfach das deutsche YouTube, so wie die meisten Leute.)
DANTE: (Ich beschuldige dich dann.)
STURMI: (Ja, das ist in Ordnung.)
DANTE: (Ich mache nur Spaß!)
SALLY: (Halte es so!)
DANTE: (Ach so, etwas näher am Wasser.) [Sturmi stimmt zu]
STURMI: (Und dann einfach nur …)
DANTE: (Ihr habt mich dazu gebracht, meine Brille abzunehmen. Das ist ein cooler Moment!)
SALLY: Komm weiter rein!
(Und schneller!)
Süß, wie kleine Sucuks.
DANTE: (Ist das so in Ordnung?)
STURMI: (Es ist perfekt!)
SALLY: (Es ist perfekt!)
DANTE: (Insgeheim denkt sie, er kann es gar nicht, aber „Es ist perfekt!") [Alle lachen]
SALLY: (Ein bisschen dicker, aber sie sind süß.)
STURMI: (Das sagen die Leute auch zu mir.) [Alle lachen]
SALLY: Okay, jetzt karamellisieren wir sie.
STURMI: (Was macht ihr Zwei so?)
EKO: (Wir nehmen einen sehr speziellen Song auf. Willst du was erzählen?)
DANTE: (Gerne. Die kurze Version ist:
Als ich vor 20 Jahren „Miss California" veröffentlicht hatte,
war ich in Florida South Beach.
Ein junger Teenager, ich weiß nicht, wie er in den Club ab 21 reinkam,
sagte: Dante, Mister California!
Es war er!
Er war sehr jung. Ich weiß nicht, wie er reinkam. Wie hast du das hinbekommen?)
EKO: (Ich hatte einen Videodreh. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich reinkam,
aber es war wie die After-Show-Party vom Videodreh.)
DANTE: Er kam zu mir und sagte, er heißt Eko Fresh, hatte gerade einen Record.
Wir fingen an zu reden. Er war ein sehr cooler Typ.
Bevor er ging, sagte er,
wir sollten Miss California in Deutschland neu auflegen.
Ich denke mir so, damals war der Song auf Platz 1
und dann hast du diesen Jungen, der gerade seinen neuen Record-Deal hat,
und will nun eine Neuauflage vom Song.
Aber wer konnte es wissen. Er ist wie ein Kartenleser. Er wusste es.
20 Jahre später haben wir nochmal darüber gesprochen.
Dann dachte ich, es ist eine echt gute Idee,
sind ins Studio, haben den Song geschnitten und - zack - hier sind wir nun!)
EKO: (Und weil es Sallys Show ist,
könnten wir vielleicht Miss Sallyfornia daraus machen.)
DANTE: (Sallyfornia? Das ist sehr interessant!)
SALLY: (Aus Swaghäusel)
STURMI: (Aus Swaghäusel)
SALLY: (Es heißt Waghäusel, aber wir nennen es Swaghäusel.)
DANTE: (Wir könnten sagen: „She's got swag.")
EKO: (Ja, ganz genau!)
DANTE: Sally got swag. Sally from Cali got swag.
SALLY: (Wir benötigen eine Punchline.)
EKO: She's Miss Sallyfornia,
hottest thing in Swaghäusel.
(Und jetzt machst du weiter!) [Alle lachen]
DANTE: (Das ist eine Herausforderung, da das Wort schwer auszusprechen ist.)
STURMI: Swaghäusel, she really likes Streusel.
EKO: She really likes Streusel. Wow
DANTE: (Was ist das?)
STURMI: (Was man auf Kuchen träufelt.)
SALLY: (Es ist Crumble.)
STURMI: (Ja genau, Crumble.)
EKO: So …
She's Miss Sallyfornia, hottest thing in Swaghäusel
and she really likes Streusel.
SALLY: Some Streusel.
EKO: (Singst du es nicht?)
DANTE: (Es ist echt hart. Meine Zunge wird sich verdrehen.)
EKO: (Wir können uns darauf einigen, dass man den Song auf fast alles anpassen kann.)
DANTE: (Das ist sehr interessant, denn bei guten Songs kann man das oft nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das so ist.)
EKO: (Jetzt sind wir hier und probieren die Spätzle.)
STURMI: Sollen wir loslegen?
SALLY: (Wir müssen sie zuerst karamellisieren.)
[Musik]
EKO: Sally is the real deal, straight outta Waghäusel.
SALLY: Straight outta Waghäusel.
EKO: Das sieht sehr lecker, muss ich euch sagen,
STURMI: Wenn das jetzt nicht gut wird, wenn ihr nicht sagt,
das wird das Beste, was ich jemals gegessen habe Dessert-mäßig …
SALLY: Es ist ein Schmecksperiment. Ich hoffe, es schmeckt auch!
STURMI: Wir fügen einen Post hinzu. Schreib mir bei Twitter.
EKO: Das sieht wirklich, wirklich, wirklich lecker aus.
SALLY: Wir haben Besuch aus Amerika und ich starte ein Schmecksperiment
und weiß nicht mal, ob es schmeckt.
STURMI: Das wird super. Guck mal, wie es aussieht! Sieht fantastisch aus!
DANTE: (Ich muss Fotos schießen. Das ist unglaublich!)
STURMI: Sardellen. [Gelächter aus dem Hintergrund]
DANTE: (Ich muss davon ein Foto machen, weil mir meine Freunde zu Hause nicht glauben werden!
Du packst Nudeln auf Sahne mit Früchten darunter - unmöglich!
STURMI: Die werden mich für verrückt verkaufen!)
(Es ist nicht das, was wir normalerweise in Deutschland machen.
Die anderen Stereotypen passen nach wie vor.)
EKO: Also ist euer eigenes Rezept? [Sturmi und Sally bejahen]
STURMI: (Das ist etwas, das sie ein „Schmecksperiment" nennt.
Sie weiß nicht, wie es schmecken wird und probiert etwas Neues.)
DANTE: (Es ist experimentell.) [Sturmi stimmt zu]
SALLY: (Es ist schmecksperimentell.)
DANTE: (Ich glaube, auch wenn es experimentell ist, hat sie ein gutes Gefühl dafür,
dass es trotz des Experiments sehr gut sein wird.)
SALLY: (Ich hoffe es!)
DANTE: Danke schön.
SALLY: Bitte schön.
STURMI: Mister Freezy.
EKO: Jawohl. Danke!
SALLY: Hier, du kriegst das Männliche.
STURMI: Danke schön. Warte!
EKO: Sagt man dann noch Prost?
SALLY: Ja, Prost Mahlzeit!
EKO: Prost Mahlzeit!
DANTE: Prost.
STURMI: Schauen wir mal. Vermischen, oder? [Sally bejaht zögerlich]
EKO: Vermischt ihr?
STURMI: Ich vermische mal, weil dann schmelzen sie noch ein bisschen.
Ja, weißt du, warum?
Weil dann schmilzt nämlich noch ein bisschen
der Rest von den gefrorenen Himbeeren durch die Hitze der frischen Spätzle.
Boah, das wird gut.
SALLY: (Die Himbeeren sind noch sehr gefroren.)
EKO: (Okay, also vermischen?) [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: So, sehr schön!
EKO & DANTE: (Danke schön! Danke, dass wir da sein durften!)
SALLY: Danke für die wunderbaren Gäste!
STURMI: Das Lied wird wahrscheinlich in der Beschreibung verlinkt.
SALLY: She's Miss Köllefornia.
EKO: Köllefornia, richtig!
STURMI: Met her right across the Dome.
SALLY: Hört gerne mal rein
und verwendet den Sound für eure Reels, für eure Story.
Teilt ihn, markiert sie und Sturmi.
Und das Rezept Gibt es wie immer in der App
- die könnt kostenlos runterladen -
oder auf Sallys-Blog.de.
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Und jetzt mal wirklich: Hat es geschmeckt oder nicht?
[Eko und Sturmi bejahen]
Ganz ehrlich?
DANTE: (Es war richtig gut! Es war großartig!)
EKO: Würde ich nicht auf meine Linie achten, würde ich noch ein Glas nehmen.
STURMI: Ich muss nicht auf die Linie achten. Ich hau mir gleich noch einen rein.
SALLY: [Lacht] Wir haben schon eine schöne Linie.
STURMI: Genau, eine Linie darf auch rund sein.
[Musik]